You know,
of all the established directors working
today,
I think the one that would feel most at
home in my world,
the world of the video essay is Edgar
Wright.
See basically what I do here every week,
like any SAS is make an argument.
The difference between me and Say New
York Times columnist Paul Krugman,
besides a phd in economics and like
accolades,
is that I use video to make my arguments
where he has only language,
but even so,
our goals are the same.
To make a persuasive and engaging
argument and just like writers pay close
attention to the flow of their words.
Carefully crafting the transitions from
one idea to the next.
I see the rhythm and momentum of my
videos as crucial to their effectiveness
and here's where I can learn a lot from
a garage and I get back to you on the
right is a master of rhythm.
What you just saw as one of many
extraordinary scene transitions from
Scott pilgrim vs the world.
It lasts about four and a half seconds,
but it's worth taking a second slower
look.
This transition is all about movement to
the right.
It kicks off with Anna Kendrick looking
to camera,
right,
which is the direction of the movement,
but she's also looking at her brother
through the splitscreen.
Her splitscreen is key framed off to the
left and so is Scott pilgrims,
but right as cleverly positioned him
left in the frame so we can bring in the
unseen right hand part of the shot to
extend the Dolly Wipe and the right of
that frame is the arm chair which wipes
across to reveal the next outdoor
setting and the UNIMOG appeal.
Letters of the school bell aid.
This transition into a shot that
continues the motion by actually
dollying to the right.
If you were to diagram out this
transition,
it would look a little like this and it
gives you a better sense of just how
much care is put into a handful of
frames.
The transitions are a site of
opportunity for Edgar right there.
Not only an opportunity for visual jokes
as my friend Tony explored briefly in
another video,
which I'll link to right here.
There are a chance to build important
connective tissue that brings the viewer
through the story.
In fact,
I think a story is a lot like an
argument.
It has to be persuasive to work.
Scott,
he only played one note for that entire
song in the beginning of this movie.
Scott pilgrim is a drift.
The breakup that defined his life for
the past year is no longer an excuse for
his sour attitude.
He begins a relationship with a 17 year
old that's clearly not serious to him,
and he's kind of just floating through
life.
It's a feeling that I'm sure a lot of
people are familiar with.
I know I am.
When everything sort of melts together
and you skip around in time from place
to place to communicate this feeling
right melts together the transitions
between settings.
He utilizes a few techniques to do this
on Scott State with knives for example,
there are a series of frame wipes that
use diabetic moving objects.
Usually people that are so seamless,
they momentarily trick the brain into
not registering the transition.
What's more?
These wipes are all accompanied by sound
effects,
which are also diabetic,
whether it's a car,
a skateboard,
the wrestling of clothes hangers,
or the beep of a sliding door all
pulling deeper into the world.
You also have shots where the reverse
shot is matched in framing,
but in a totally different location.
I mean,
this is really cool because right is
using the rules of cinema against you.
You're not trained to think that a scene
transition could come between a shot
reverse shot,
so you're already engaging with the next
place before you realize that you've
left the last one.
When you think back on this sequence,
it's hard to remember all the locations
as distinct,
which is exactly what Scott is feeling.
I told you like 50 times,
party retard all throughout Scott
Pilgrim,
right?
Never misses a chance to use a creative
transition,
whether it's from scene to scene,
Oh hey,
it's tonight at the run or within scenes
from shot to shot.
I think the overall effect of this is
two fold.
Not only do the wipes and whip pans and
match cuts draw you along the story as
it unfolds,
but they also make you into a more
observant viewer.
They're transitions that disappeared the
first time you watch and stand out the
second time or vice versa.
I mean,
where exactly is the scene transition
here?
It's happening completely off screen or
rather behind the screen.
My guess is either that the house set is
on wheels or the bathroom itself is
being spun around to face another
backdrop,
whichever it is.
The transition is disorienting in the
best way and because what's happening
isn't possible.
You're encouraged to sort of put the
film together and interactivity that's
appropriate in a movie about gaming.
What's important is that the film goer
is involved and engrossed at the same
time.
This delicate balance is achieved
through transitions that are often
lyrical,
like a kind of visual poetry in the most
unlikely place.
It might be worth noting too that Scott
pilgrim is a story about a transitionary
period in the hero's slight for period
between knowing who you were and
deciding who you're going to be.
A life's transitions are harder to
navigate than those in film or a video
essay,
but all of them have to be persuasive
and persuasion is about more than the
words or the images or the ideas you
use.
It's also about how you connect.
Now.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
There is a new nerdwriter episode every
Wednesday,
so if you click right there,
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all the videos.
Guys,
I'm in Venice.
Can you see?
Can you see that?
I'm in Venice,
Italy.
That is amazing.
I'm here for a month and a half working,
living,
exploring.
It's this place is like a dream and
being here as a dream for me anyway.
I have to think squarespace for
sponsoring this video.
They make sleek,
intuitive websites.
I just made one called the nerd
writer.net.
You sign up for a year,
you can get a free domain name and if
you use the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
You know it's really easy to do.
Go make one.
It's fun.
Thanks guys for that and I will see the
rest of you.
Hopefully next Wednesday I'm in.